So Andrea, we've set up a good
foundation for our app and
now we're ready to add
in the vocab words.
>> Do you have an idea of
what words we can include?
>> Yeah, I came up with a list of words,
here they are.
>> Cool, this is great.
>> Yeah, at one point I was thinking
about using words for animals and
places, but I figured that
phrases would be more useful.
>> Yeah, I think phrases will be fun for
our students to learn.
>> [FOREIGN]
>> [LAUGH] Sounds great.
So Jessica, how do we go ahead and
build the next step of the app?
>> Yeah,
there's a lot of words on this list.
How about we just focus on
the first category for now, so
the numbers category.
>> I see, so
we get the numbers list working and
then we can just repeat the same pattern
for the family, phrases and color words.
>> Yeah, exactly, so let's revisit the
course map and I can give our students
an overview of what we're
going to cover in this lesson.
>> [FOREIGN].
>> So right now we're in
lesson two out of four.
So here are the details of what
we're going to cover in Lesson 2.
So first, we're going to learn about how
to store a list of words in the app,
and we're going to talk about data
structures, such as Arrays and
ArrayLists to help us store these words.
Next, we'll learn how to
display a list of words.
And here's an example of what that
looks like in our numbers activity.
Then we'll go on to display a list
of English and Miwok word pairs.
And here's what that looks
like in the numbers activity.
And lastly, we'll get to add the words
from all the remaining categories.
So here's a sneak peek of what that
looks like in all the activities.